hey youtubers is Charlie and a new
Monster was spotted on the set of Doctor
Who don't you just love it when they
film outdoors we don't know anything
about him but the fans that were on set
that day said that they started calling
him the mole just because his hands look
like they were used for digging but it
does give us a good opportunity to talk
about our top 10 favorite monsters that
we want to see come back I just love the
way the pictures make it look like he's
walking around interrupting people's
picnics in Cardiff in related news I'm
also working on a breakdown of the
episode descriptions for series 8 and a
video for a special thing that's going
on on the Channel in April so I'll
be doing two separate videos for that
I'm also working on a Q&A video so be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
I'll try to start posting it by this
weekend especially that Q&A video so
here we go here's the top 10 monsters
that I'd like to see comeback number 10
the Beast easily one of the biggest you
know if not scariest monsters he claims
to have been from before the normal
universe existed you know pre universe
and something about the way they've been
using the cracks makes me feel like
ancient things including the Time Lords
will be trying to use them to come back
digital effects have evolved a lot since
we last saw him during series 2 but they
did use him again during a comic book
story where he escaped to earth and
tried to get revenge on the Tenth Doctor
one of the few things that you know
really old monsters like this are good
for aside from killing people is ancient
knowledge I'm really hoping that doctor
has a few good Sherlock style mysteries
to solve clueing for looks all over
space and time just sounds like so much
fun
on to number nine the ice warriors the
last time we saw a grand marshal skaldak
in series 7 he was being rescued we
don't really know where they went which
means they're still at large even though
the last time we saw him he was having
his Captain America death odd moment
it's possible that the doctor could
enlist his aid in a battle or two you
know not all Doctor Who monsters have to
be villains despite evidence to the
contrary more pre-universe characters on
to number 8 the great intelligence we
never really got a definitive answer as
to whether or not the great intelligence
was really destroyed when ever tried to
enter to the doctor's time stream being
so ancient and omniscient I really find
it hard to believe that it would be
defeated so easily on to number 7 the
Reapers as much as the doctor messes
with the space-time continuum I'm
surprised they haven't come back sooner
the cracks are more of a tear in space
than a tear in time so those wouldn't
necessarily bring them back even though
they do exist all over time and space
but it does seem like the doctor crosses
his own time stream at least once every
series there have to be repercussions
for that so obviously something has to
fight the doctor in the ass at some
point you know why not a monster to
literally bite him in the ass and here's
the oldie but a goodie number six the
pyro vials from fires of Pompeii how
great would it be for the doctor and
Clara to revisit Pompeii in some way or
at least visit somewhere that allows the
pyro vials to come back just as a nice
nod to Capaldi's other character from
that episode plus it would totally be a
fun nod to Karen Gillan too you know I
don't expect her to cameo until the next
day anniversary special but any
reference to the original episode would
also be a subtle reference to her
character from before she was cast as
Amy Pond there's been a lot of rumors
that series 8 will pay some form of
homage to fire some pop pay but the only
evidence I've seen is just the fan made
poster and number 5 the spiders
including a new great one originally
seen in planet of the spiders this just
sounds like it would be fun like Martin
Freeman had with the spiders of Mirkwood
during The Hobbit those spiders were
much bigger than the one sin planet of
the spiders but I just love the imagery
they evoke and the idea that at least in
the original story a giant spider queen
is trying to ascend a higher state of
existence I think if they did make it
back into a story it would be you know
something much less cosmic if series 8
is supposed to have this or driven tone
then I think that spiders just building
a large layer feeding on people would be
enough you know like the Cybermen in
closing time just something a little
more sinister and not something quite so
grand number four the old ones you know
something from classic ooh that was
really big but got a shout out during
the series 7 finale there another
pre-universe monster and are really more
effective as an idea like the great
intelligence acting through different
physical bodies in classic who their
biology was actually quite a bit
different between members that race
instead of like the whisper men you know
they're all look the same but they
actually had the power to fundamentally
change the properties of the universe I
think of them as being like inspiration
for the Q continuum and Star Trek so
whenever you think of them imagine a
more sinister version of John Delancey
and this is fun instead of Patrick
Stewart just imagine the 7th doctor
and now just to get a little bit more
grant number three the rest of the
pre-universe creatures i already
mentioned the beast and the old ones but
there are actually more things that
existed before the creation of our
universe in in the Doctor Who world that
is it's called the N universe whenever
our universe was created and theirs was
destroyed some of them were able to pass
into it just travel into the new
universe since the cracks exist all over
time and space now I'm expecting some of
those other things you know besides the
Time Lords to try and come in that will
always be a hanging threat until the
doctor undoes the damage from whatever
the cracks were created remember that
happened when he rebooted the universe
and he's not gonna unroot the universe
so it's a big big problem and number 2
starting to get a little bit more modern
the matrix that is the Time Lords matrix
not really a monster but much more
relevant is an idea given the current
state of our digital existence the last
big story featuring the matrix was
during the ultimate foe which also
featured the valued if you're not
familiar the Time Lords use the matrix
to store all their collected knowledge
and predict the future The Sixth Doctor
was actually able to physically enter it
using the key of Rassilon which is kind
of funny and makes it seem like the
Wachowskis totally ripped Doctor Who off
since that movie was made 13 years after
ultimate foe it's not really just a
computer either it's actually a micro
universe kind of like the pocket
universe where Gallifrey exists right
now I don't expect to see any more Time
Lord stories though until the doctor
communicates with them again or finds a
safer way to restore them to a normal
universe and I don't think that's gonna
happen anytime soon but I do think he's
gonna communicate with him before the
end of series 8 and my number one
monster that I would love to see come
back the valley or the dark doctor he
escaped during that episode ultimate foe
and while a lot of people think the
master is the doctor's ultimate foe I
really think it's the Valor since the
master is more of an antihero you know
sometimes crazy person as opposed to the
Valor who I see is more of a black cat
wearing villain you know who could be a
greater enemy to you than your own self
so now it's your turn let me know which
monsters do you want to see come back
from classic ooh or even the new whose
stories often is also going to be
creating some new monsters as we've seen
so no matter what series eight is going
to be a ton of fun it
if you like horror stories so like I
said I'm gonna be posting that Q&A video
this weekend be sure to leave me all
your questions and then I have a
breakdown of the episode details as well
as a special horror video I'm gonna be
doing my top 10 scary Doctor Who
episodes from classic ooh that is just
classic whoo because that special horror
marathon that's coming so right now
click here to learn more about series 8
and click here to get that Q&A video all
of the annotation as soon as I post it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives